Thank you Ms. Akana for coming by the office today.
For the chance to interview for a Fortune 500 Company?
Thank you Mr. Wang.
Well, my first question has to be:  Where do you see yourself in 5 years?
Hopefully doing your job.  Haha!
That's a good one!
Cocky.  I like it.
What about 6 years?
Oh, I did not see that question coming.  Uhm.
Well, I'm going to be optimistic here and say
on the cusp of upper management.
Being groomed to take over by company president.
Mmm.  Interesting.
How about 30 years?
Uh, well I would be 56 at that point.
Ready for retirement.  But hopefully with a good health regimen
and an active lifestyle
and in an advanced state of medicine I'll be well enough to pursue my new calling,
motivational speaking.
Gotchya.  Well you know what your resume is great
and your qualifications--
How about 100 years?
Well, sir.  I would probably be dead in 100 years.
Most likely from the cancer that runs in my family.
That's fantastic.  How about 1,000 years?
Sir, I don't see how that's relevant--
Where do you see yourself in 1,000 years?  Do you want this job or not Ms. Akana?
Answer the god damned question!
Wong Fu Productions will develop the ability to revive dead
human tissue as means of providing enough soldiers for their continued evolvement
in a still war-stricken Middle East.
The program would make me its first test subject.
I would become an immortal cyborg.
Fascinating.
How about 1 million years?
Sir I can't know--
1 million years!
Humanity ending war over water is inevitable, with our destructive species extinct
the Earth can sustain itself from that much longer but ultimately
it will be obliterated by meteor E-1779 or our sun going supernova.
Cyborg or not, I would be destroyed.
There will be nothing left.
The Earth, a lifeless hulk.  Blasted into nothingness
by a cataclysmic galactic event taking your half human half machine remains with it?
There's just no room in this company for that kind of negativity.
Th-thank you for your time.
Another one down, huh boss?
You ever gonna find an applicant you like?
You know what? I'm not even trying to hire anyone.  I'm just collecting ideas for my Sci-Fi novel.
*chuckles*
That's so like you.
You wanna co-write this with me?
What about a crazy half-squid half-tarantula?
There's like some erotic aspects that we could work on.
You sick fuck.
*laughs*